For decades, scientists have believed...
...depression is linked to lower levels of serotonin in the brain.
That belief has shaped treatment...
...and helped create a multibillion dollar market for antidepressant drugs.
But it may be wrong.
According to research published in the Journal Molecular Psychiatry,...
...there is no convincing evidence...
...that problems with serotonin actually cause depression.
The findings stand to change the way depression is treated...
...and the use of antidepressants going forward.
For more, I want to bring in Dr. Mitch Prinstein.
He's the chief science officer at the American Psychological Association.
Dr. Prinstein, I'm gonna do something you are not supposed to do,...
...which is ask you a triple-barreled question.
First of all, what is serotonin,...
...what did we think about it before this study,...
...and what is the new way to think about it now?
Sure, okay, serotonin is a neurotransmitter.
It helps to move signals from one neuron in the brain...
...to other neurons in the brain.
We know that serotonin, selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors or SSRIs,...
...Prozac, is a really common one people know about,...
...has been effective in reducing symptoms of depression.
So people thought that maybe a lack of serotonin was the problem,...
...was the reason why people were getting depressed.
Now we know that that’s probably not the best explanation.